comme tout bon danseur j'invite toutes
les personnes qui sont là à
m'accompagner dans un petit teaser de
corps agathe fauves adèle vous fait
entrer dans la danse pour la sixième
année consécutive la chorégraphe
coordonne danse à l'école
une nouvelle édition à la saveur toute
particulière
le candidat tout transformer mais après
on n'a jamais lâché
en partenariat avec dow avec linda on a
toujours on a été on était convaincus du
fait que ça soit essentiel que cette
aventure existe et aille au bout d'une
manière ou d'une autre
pendant deux jours les participants ont
fait découvrir à leur famille le travail
d'une année quatorze classes de la
maternelle au lycée sur toute
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
c'est un bonheur de voir des enfants de
tous âges dansent et se retrouvent et
surtout prendre du plaisir un moment où
on sort d'une pandémie où on a fait un
classement entre l'essentiel et non
essentiels la participation de ses
enfants et de leurs familles montre à
quel point il est essentiel de continuer
à avoir une vie qui ne soit pas
exclusivement tournée vers les besoins
vitaux mais aussi vers la culture vers
le bonheur de se retrouver développer
son autonomie vaincre sa timidité danse
à l'école existe depuis 22 ans en
partenariat avec l'éducation nationale